In this politically fire.
Hold on one second. What does,
what are we going after me? Two
people for, for me taking in the back,
grabbing attention,
grabbing your purse or your for you
sucking my Dick for a movie role or for
something like that. All those things
really don't exist in my life. Right?
I have a wife and I have a child.
They don't exist them. Right.
If you want to come at me for sucking
my Dick and night in 2002 we were dope.
Both doing blow guide be my guest,
be my guest,
but I want to see footage. I can't be,
I'mZ , I'm Zari and take it and just,
you know what I'm saying?
There's a lot of people out there.
They're going to get me to look at this
other guy for years he was known as a
heroin addict,
never got a clue of of sexual misconduct
and some chick said she molested when
he was 11 years old and now he's like,
you need that,
you need that and the chicks on drugs.
She's doing the press conference while
she's on drugs. What's his name? Brother?
The one,
the guy that was in heat that the narrow,
put them in the Rehab himself and then
he married Heidi Fleiss for awhile.
Who was with Heidi Fleiss from Tom.
That guy's been a junkie for 2000 years.
All of a sudden,
why can't I remember his last more size?
All of a sudden some girl comes
up when she had 26 kitchen. Yeah,
he molested me on a movie set when
I was 11 that's great and Dandy dog,
but you can't ruin some of these life now,
but what do you think is happening?
This is my question like why are,
why are people accepting these,
these situations like the Chris Hardwick
situation or why is everybody instantly
thinking that the guy's guilty? No one
giving him a chimp benefit of doubt.
No court, no justice court. There's
no nothing and in some some cases,
like the worst case was garrison Keillor.
Garrison Keillor is the host of the lake.
Woebegone chronicles like this
radio show on PBS, I think it is.
Is that what it is?
He apparently hugged the woman and
his hand went down her back. This is,
this is the depiction.
And he apologized to her and he
sent her an email and she said,
don't worry about it. It's no big deal.
It was nothing. And then they continued,
I believe, to correspond and we're
friends again. And then this,
all the stuff started
happening with out Franken.
And then he had this complaint
brought up by this woman.
She reintroduced it and
said that a long time ago.
He put his hand on my back
and they canceled the show
and they took his name off
of it and they did it like really quickly.
And it's one of those things
where you just go, okay, really,
like the guy in one moment in
time touches someone's back.
I don't know if it was creepy or not.
Let's assume it was a terrible error.
And it was creepy. I don't think it was,
I don't know. I'm not saying I know,
but that's it.
Just touching someone's back.
And that is a hysterical reaction.
That is hysteria.
That's almost the definition of hysteria.
You're not talking about an evil person
talking about a person who touched
someone's back.
Like we gotta be real careful what you
destroy a person's whole life with.
So on the one side you have
the worst case scenario,
which is like a bill Cosby who's
drugging people and raping people.
So worst case scenario for these powerful
elite type people that are getting
these women into their web and
Proton, we want to help him, right?
He's another one which
day we're all in on it.
And everybody knew about it
for you as they knew about,
written into his contract,
it was a sexual harassment clauses were
in his contract, right? It wasn't that.
It was known for years. They sure
we're correct. We really hot under.
That bothers me about Harvey [inaudible],
Harvey, what we got and died every body,
there's a lot of people that have to be
indicted and this is one of the things
that mark feeling right now. This
should be, this should be a Rico act.
Wow. This is a Rico act. Agents, managers,
Oprah, Eddie. Cause
everybody knew every body.
But here's the question. How much did
they know? Everybody knew in 2005 right?
Everybody knew Joe Diaz was a cold feet.
That's a different thing though, man.
Stay. Let's pretend, but the
same thing. Okay, but let's
go. Joe Diaz is a coke feet.
It's 2007 Joe Diaz comes to a party house.
There's two cell phones missing.
Okay.
Okay. Let me, let me say this though.
Do you think that it's possible that his
behavior was shielded from some of the
people that he interacted
with like Hillary Clinton
or Oprah or Bill Clinton or
whoever that was, that they, some high
profile people that he interacted with.
Is it possible that they didn't know?
Is it possible that they just
thought he was a pussy hound? No.
Or do you think they all knew he was a
pussy hound and they heard little chitter
chatter, but it's okay. It's okay.
They would just let him show
me. That's number one. That's
crazy. Number two, Jamie,
you're ready for this? Oh Jesus.
Okay. I see Joe a whatever. Not now,
probably five years ago.
Yeah,
I see Joan and the first thing I
had to go with Joe before you leave,
don't forget, I got to tell you the
story. What was that story would be about?
About Benson Henderson is choke about
a joke that somebody said the store,
no,
I want a place I went to
and some chick took me in the back of
suck my dick on the car and then she stuck
a finger up my ass.
And that's what we talked about.
So if that's what we talked about,
you're going to look me in the fucking
face like a man that you are in,
the men that you've been around and
telling me Harvey Weinstein turned to Brad
or his other bodies and listen,
remind me to tell you a story
about that dirty fucking battle
for sure. Okay. That for sure.
But that was that. That's
that, that's been admitted.
I think they've had conversations.
Oh my God. If you don't pick the wig,
Ben Affleck and the other guy,
and I'm not offended though,
but I'm just talking about
boys were boys, right? Yes.
What you won't say to Jamie, you'll say
to me, you go and you watch blind date.
No,
I'm never watches a movie.
Blind blind crackers going off.
And there's a movie named blind date with
Bruce Willis. Oh, I remember that movie.
And Kim Bassinger, how Larry
is. Kim Bassinger steals
the show when she walks in,
the Japanese lady, she was like, you know,
you're entitled to 50% of your
husband's assets in California.
And the Chinese woman kept saying me,
no, speak English. They'll speak English.
And I was like,
you didn't even tell him 50% and she
opens up the the 50% 50% that movie is a
great word, but this is seen
in the opening of that movie.
Both of those actors are around where
the guy comes up to him and he goes,
you're not going to believe what happened
last night. And Bruce Willis goes, hey,
we go one of these fucking sex
stories again. I think it was,
saw him at spa and go,
I was like ham for dinner.
I walk out and some lady pulls
up with a limo and I say,
I've never been in a little
moment. She goes, we'll get in.
And we were riding down sunset hard times
in the summer and next thing you know,
she's sucking my Dick.
She's got leotards on eating her ass and
he's telling the story in Bruce Willis
or something. He goes, no, no. Why
does this always happen to you?
This is some other bullshit. He goes,
[inaudible] and it goes in his pocket.
He starts whipping out Polaroids.
That I've always known one of
those guys in my life. Of course,
we've all known one guy in my life.
That was the difference between that guy
and what Harvey, why don't know. Yeah,
I know that.
But I also believed that Harvey Weinstein
was telling people he probably was,
because listen for everybody who told him.
Was he telling him that he
was holding people down?
What are they usually tell him? What
was he telling? He was raping pieces.
A piece of ass. No, not at all.
Do you think that he did well,
you got anybody to use a piece of ass.
She's a piece of ass.
You've got to see her suck a dick.
She'll do anything. She's an animal.
Well that's what we do as men.
We're braggadocio.
So do you think it was like a community
of that were actors and actresses?
I think he had four or five guys
that knew what he was doing.
I want you to remember being 27
and having for your boys that would
come back every Monday with a different
story to karate school.
Yeah. I hate harass.
I fucked her on fire. Whatever the fuck
it is that you do. He told somebody,
somebody knew about all these stories.
So my agents knew somebody because for,
for the hundred of them that said no
and whatever that had to be 25 he was
playing the percentages, Joe. Well
after they, in fact they said yes.
They blame that one girl.
That one girl that did rounders,
they accused her. Yeah, I heard that.
That played Matt Damon's girlfriend.
She was,
she went from being an
extra and fucking uh,
Donnie Brasco to being a
guest opposite fucking, yeah.
If you want to Donnie Brasco, she's,
what's his name? Sonny black's girlfriend.
You know what I mean? Line.
She hasn't met movie zero,
zero smart move.
And then a year later she's
a fucking guests opposite.
So there's a bunch of them that said yes,
but you fault the girl for doing that
over girl decides to chocolate Harvey
Weinstein on her own freewill
when we come here with a dream.
And there's two ways
to enhance that dream.
Because I always knew that I wasn't good
looking man. I always knew I was fat.
Now I was knew I was r rated hard to
listen to what I always knew that I was
funny.
So I always worked on being funny.
I didn't think somebody was gonna let me
suck their dick or eat that pussy to be
a star. So that was never in my
mind. But think about people who,
how many people have you met with
sell that. So when this town,
how many people have come
and gone in front of you?
The reason why our friendship is still
intact it because you know I'm a hard
worker. You know our, he's a hard
worker. You respect hard work.
How many times have you
pulled me aside and said,
look at this fucking clown and
you're not trying to be judgemental.
You just know that he's pulling
the wool over some of these eyes.
We know who's talking to the talk
and we know who's walking the walk.
We see it on stage, we hear about it.
You don't need Twitter of Facebook.
We hear about it. We get to that
club, the club on the rotate.
Joe and Joey was here two weeks ago. He
was falling asleep on stage. You know,
you're his shit, right?
So it's the same day.